[Music]
Almond consumption dates back to
biblical times they're even mentioned in
the Old Testament around 100 AD
the ancient Romans showered newlyweds
with almonds this ritual came from the
belief that they increased fertility but
today it's the nutritional value of
almonds that keeps us coming back for
more almonds are a guilt-free snack
they're full of vitamins minerals and
protein more than 80 percent of the
world's almonds come from California
we're growing conditions are ideal upon
arrival at a processing facility the
almonds are still encased in leathery
halls they flow through equipment that
comes out to free the next machine
called a deist owner targets any rocks
air blows through it to separate the
lighter almonds from the stones the
almonds travel between a rubber roller
and belt this spins off the hauls and
releases the almonds the operator
periodically examines the D hold almonds
vibrating decks with slots sort the
almonds by size the system also shakes
off halt material and vacuums it up the
almonds head to a gravity table for
finer separation the spent hulls and
other material float to one side while
heavier contaminants float to the other
the in shell almonds tumble down
channels cameras examine the shells for
imperfections and look for contaminants
then a blast of compressed air knocks
them out of the flow these are some of
the contaminants that have been removed
at another facility machinery will now
grade the almonds according to the
condition of their shells
once again the almonds fall through the
open air and a computerized camera scans
them for broken shells and other flaws a
compressed air gun then knocks the
flawed almonds out of the mix the
almonds bounce along a vibrating grid
and any kernels or missed shell
fragments fall through finally people
sort through the almonds and reject any
that don't have perfect shells they also
toss out any contaminants the mechanized
sorting system missed some buyers will
pay a premium for the best nuts the
almonds with broken shells will have the
shells removed these raw almonds are
also sorted by size they flow onto a
vibrating conveyor further along the
conveyor has holes the smaller almonds
fall through these holes and into bins
the larger almonds continue forward
these larger kernels are worth more and
will be sold separately from the smaller
ones as with the in shell elements good
looks are important
a camera photographs the cascading
almond kernels and a computer scans the
images the system knocks the
less-than-perfect almonds out of the
production stream next the almonds head
towards a robot along the way
another camera sends the images to a
computer scanner this one has been
programmed to find chips scratches and
even small broken bits the computer
sends the coordinates of the damaged
almonds to the robot the robot then
finds them and plucks them out of the
mix a human inspector now picks out any
imperfect almonds that the robotic
system missed their flaws are just
superficial they still taste the same so
these almonds will be processed into
chocolate bars almond butter or milk
baked goods and cereals the perfect
almond kernels travel forward just ahead
Machinery moves cardboard boxes into an
open position on a packaging carousel
the sprayers apply glue to the bottom
flaps and pushers close them sealing the
boxes the almonds now arrive at a scale
it releases them into the boxes in
approximately 50 pound batches
these big boxes of almonds will be
shipped to other facilities to be
processed into other products smaller
amounts will be packaged for consumer
use
[Music]
a snack anyone can crack or enjoy
pre-cracked almonds are a natural and
nutritious choice no wonder they're
consumed by the handful
[Music]